this is a speech that got china's most
famous entrepreneur jack ma
into trouble
he kind of slid directly into criticism
of the chinese regulatory environment
saying things for example that
china has a pawnshop mentality very
traditional old school
but it didn't come off as very funny
ma is the lead founder of e-commerce
giant alibaba
which the fintech giant ant group grew
out of both companies have redefined
china's economy
but mod directly challenged the people
who oversee the country's economy during
this speech
the speech really triggered the central
government
uh all the way up to president xi
jinping
so how did the model of chinese
innovation and entrepreneurial success
end up facing the ire of beijing we look
at three of his public appearances to
find out
in the early days you knew jack moore
because of his humor and his charisma
than for his company
duncan clark first met ma when alibaba
was set up in 1999 as a fledgling
e-commerce company
the internet consultant based in beijing
even wrote a book about his friend
he had this sense that he was destined
for great things
maul lived up to his own expectations as
his startup grew into a tech powerhouse
and he rubbed shoulders with global
elites
few people could be a better example of
the
china dream jack ma basically
was the best pr for the chinese
government
we're just depressed by he wants to make
a difference
be it the advancement of technology in
china overall
or geopolitical matters as ma became the
friendly face of china's economic rise
he found himself more involved in
politics business and political leaders
would like to say that they knew jack
when they visited china would sometimes
heads of state
would irritate the party actually by
making
appointments for jack
[Music]
one of the most talked about encounters
was when maul went to trump tower to
meet the president-elect
less than two weeks before the
inauguration high quality man
thank you jeff the foreign ministry was
in dark about this meeting
they didn't know about it until after
the meeting was all over the news
and we also think the china-usa
relationship should be strengthened
some officials felt like he should have
stayed
in his own lane which is
being a businessman not crossing over
to sensitive issues
and this wouldn't be the last time ma
crossed the line
since 2013 ma had been slowly signaling
that he'd make his way out of alibaba
i can compete with the bill gates who
can retire earlier
then finally in 2019 he officially
stepped down as executive chairman of
the company
at the age of fifty-five
it didn't really come as a surprise to a
lot of officials
and some of them thought he's smart he's
basically wrapping up a very successful
career
with me but ma's retirement didn't mean
he was going away from the public eye
he pursued philanthropic causes and
became a judge on an african reality
television show
similar to shark tank let the
competitors worry about you
ma also didn't fully leave the tech
world after retirement
he remained the controlling shareholder
of ant which has changed the way many
people in china spend
borrow save and invest the company has
also worked with and competed against
state-owned banks and other financial
institutions in china
this company ant has been acting like a
bank
without being regulated as a bank and
has amassed 12 consumer data
that data has allowed ant group to stay
many many steps ahead of traditional
commercial lenders
it was very lucrative for ant so much so
that the company landed in the
crosshairs of chinese regulators
the central bank had wanted to tighten
the school
over his companies for quite a long time
[Music]
but because of his tremendous ability
to combine his entrepreneurial ambitions
with his political savvy he had been
able to
basically fend off that kind of pressure
but the clash between ma
and financial regulators all came to a
head on october 24th
last year
on this occasion in shanghai what he was
saying was directly
criticizing actually people in the room
which includes very senior figures in
the chinese government in financial
[Music]
regulations
this speech in shanghai was maybe a
culmination of where we've gone from
total humility in the early days to
perhaps a touch of hubris
less than two weeks after this speech
chinese regulators took action
ultimately it was president xi who
personally
intervened in the matter called off the
end ipo
and instructed financial regulators do a
thorough
investigation into the risks posed by
jack ma's financial and technology
empire
and has said it's moving quickly to try
and address the concerns of regulators
after the shanghai speech ma was nowhere
to be seen
but three months later he reappeared in
a video that was posted to chinese
social media by a government-backed news
outlet called tianmu news
it showed him addressing village
teachers in china
senior officials don't want to send the
wrong message to
the chinese entrepreneurs okay you know
once you get big
this is the consequence for you the
party leadership
obviously want to have very firm control
over the economy but another
top priority for the central leadership
is to
keep innovation going that's
very big challenge for china going
forward
and alibaba and ant are still a major
part of china's tech future
but it's an open question what that
means for jack ma
is there a way for him to redeem himself
the jury is definitely still out